الان ام ليس بعد
طموحك بالاطلسي سيبحث في فيرنيوس يضغط
الاوكرانيون لانتزاع تعهد من قمه النيتو
بمنحهم مسار الانضمام السريع على خطى
فنلندا والسويد او وعد بتلقي دعوه
للانضمام الى الحلف بعد انتهاء الحرب
ربما زادت غبطه الرئيس الاوكراني
بعد الكلمات الطيبه التي سمعها من الشركاء
في جولته الاوروبيه الشرقيه الاخيره
وبما قيل له تحديدا في تركيا عن استحقاق
بلاده عضويه حلف شمال الاطلسي لكن واشنطن
لا تستعجل كما يبدو فتح باب النيتو امام
كييف
لا اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين مستعدون للانضمام
الى النيتو لقد بذلت وقتا طويلا في محاوله
الحفاظ على تماسك الحلف ولا اعتقد ايضا ان
هناك اجماعا في النيتو حول ما اذا كان
سيتم ضم اوكرانيا الى عضويته ونحن في خضم
الحرب فان نحن فعلنا ذلك الان سنكون
ملزمين بالدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضي الحلف
وسنكون جميعا في حاله حرب مع روسيا
يقول بايدن ذلك ولما تهدا بعد الزوبعه
التي اثارها قرار ادارته تزويد اوكرانيا
بدخائر عنقوديه لاستخدامها على الارجح في
هجومها المضاد الذي مر عليه شهر واكثر
انها اسلحه تلقى انتقادات واسعه لانها
تقتل عشوائيا من خلال نظام يطلق مجموعه من
الذخائر المتفجره الاصغر حجمه وهي مصممه
للانفجار قبل الارتطام او عنده او بعده
وتتسبب بمقتل العديد من المدنيين
نتحدث عن ذخائر محظوره من معظم اعضاء
النيتو لكن الولايات المتحده تواصل
استخدامها لا يبدو ان الخلافه حول هذه
المساله سينال من الاصرار الغربي على
المضي في دعم اوكرانيا لكن يبدو ان دعمها
عسكريا شيء والاسراع بضمها الى التحالف
العسكري الغربي شيء اخر فهل بالاول يستعار
عن الثاني
تعول اوكرانيا اساسا على دعم دول اوروبا
الشرقيه الاعضاء في النيتو لاصدار جدول
واضح لضمها للحلف
وبينما تتنقل بريطانيا بين الدعم والوساطه
تجنح الولايات المتحده والمانيا وقياده
الحلف للدعم الحذر مع الاخذ في الحسبان
انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو لن يكون ممكنا الا
بعد انتهاء الحرب الروسيه عليها
ليس هذا الجدل كله ما تود روسيا يبحثه
قاده حلف شمال الاطلسي في قمه ليتوانيا